it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
[Music]
I know how much this would have
would have meant to her
a South African choir brings Simon
Cowell to tears on America's Got Talent
after performing late contestant night
birds song it's okay I like being
surprised and seeing things I've never
seen before season 18 got off to an
emotional start when the zanzi youth
choir took the stage right off the bat
the judges recognized The Familiar tune
California in the summer time
[Music]
I changed my
money
[Music]
Bird real name Jane marchevsky sang that
original song it's okay during the
season 16 auditions
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay if
you're lost we're all a little lost and
it's all right Simon even gave nightbird
his Golden Buzzer but sadly her battle
against cancer forced her to exit the
competition early and she died shortly
after I cannot say thank you enough for
the opportunity to to have a moment to
share my story but night Bird's memory
lives on in her music clearly making an
impact on the zanzi youth choir
[Music]
oh
my God it's okay it's okay it's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
this song has been such a pillow of
strength for us as a choir through
difficult times we just want to continue
the Legacy and that's why we chose
for judges Heidi Klum Sophia Vergara and
Howie Mandel the performance hit close
to home and
[Applause]
I heard that song and your voices are
fantastic that was the perfect ADT
audition I'll always remember nightbird
and to see that it touched people on the
other side of the globe unbelievable I
feel like we are the luckiest people in
the world who have the best seats in the
world right up front and once they got
to Simon he couldn't hold back his tears
I know how much this would have
would have meant to her
it would
right until the end she was so
passionate about sharing her music and
this has gone all over the world and
you've come back here with the most
amazing tribute it was just
breathtaking like nightbird the choirs
audition earned them the golden buzzer
and unfortunately people come from all
over the world now to audition for the
show so you know we have a lot of people
living in the U.S we have a lot of
people around the world so you're never
going to run out of talent
um
better not otherwise we don't have a
show
foreign